كنت مريضًا ، لكن لم يكن نوع
المرض الذي يمكن اكتشافه باستخدام
الأشعة السينية لفاحص الدم ، فمن السهل جدًا التعرف على
حالتي كانت الانشغال المفرط.
هو مرض يشعر معظمنا بأن
لدينا فهمًا بديهيًا لماهية
الفكرة ولكن وفقًا
للقاموس الطبي الفوضوي لأن هذا
ضعف يمنع
الجسم والعقل من العمل بشكل طبيعي
ويتجلى ذلك من خلال علامات وأعراض غير عادية
لذلك دعونا نتحدث عن ماهية
المرض في هذه المقالة حيث لم تكن أبدًا من
السهل أن تكون الأعمال التجارية السهلة مدمرة جدًا
لصحتي العقلية وكوني
سأأخذك في رحلة لمدة عامين ونصف
العام من حياتي  حيث أنشأت
حلقة مفرغة من الانشغال ، فما
هي الأعراض التي مررت
بها ، لذا فقد
كرست كل دقيقة تقريبًا من يومي
لبعض الأنشطة المتعلقة بالعمل في ربيع عام 2015 ، فما هي الأعراض التي
مررت بها؟
اتحاد الطلاب كنت عبارة عن شاي محاسبي ،
قمت بتدريب طالب في المدرسة الإعدادية حبي
لمدة أربع سنوات وقمت بالتناوب بين 13
ناديًا مختلفًا بدءًا من السنة الأولى ، لذا
فهذه مجرد لقطة لما كنت
أقوم به في الفصول الدراسية التي تعتقد أنني
سأستمع إليها بنشاط  أستاذي لم يكن هناك
أوقات حصرية بالنسبة لي ، اعتدت إسقاط
رسائل البريد الإلكتروني لإرسالها إلى أعضائي أو كتابة
أذونات إلى مكاتب الجامعة المختلفة
200 أوقات استراحة للاستحمام بالنسبة لنا ،
هذه هي 10 دقائق فقط
في اليوم حيث نغني بأعلى صوت كما نحن
هل يمكننا ورقصنا رقصنا
في الحمام ، لكن بالنسبة لي ، فإن أوقات الاستحمام
واستراحات المرحاض تعني أنني سوف
أمارس عروضي التقديمية أو أن أقوم
بصياغة جميع أوراق المصطلحات التي
كان عليّ كتابتها عقليًا ، لذلك
يجب أن يتم احتساب كل دقيقة من يومي بالنسبة لي  اعتقدت
دائمًا أنني يجب أن أهرع إلى ذلك إلى وجهتي التالية
أو اضطررت إلى التحقق من
شيء من قائمتي المحددة في المرتبة
الثانية فقدت ضرورياتي الأساسية الأولوية ،
وبالكاد قلت إنني لم أذهب مطلقًا إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية التي
تخطيتها  هل أنا طعام قمامة ، لذلك
كانت صحتي العقلية تتجه حقًا إلى
حاجز الصرف رقم ثلاثة ، لقد
أغضبتني من أصغر الأشياء ،
وشددت على أنها جعلتني غاضبة مما جعلني
امرأة غير سعيدة للغاية وأعتقد أن أمي
هي أكبر إعلان لأنني  كان من
الممكن أن يكون عقلي مثقلًا للغاية لدرجة
أنه لم يكن لديّ
تذكرة القدرة على تلقي أي معلومات
اتصل بي أي لا يوجد حاجز jikan رقم أربعة
لم
أكن سعيدًا لأنني قد أكون غير سارة ، شعرت دائمًا
بالسعادة لأنني شعرت دائمًا بالعبء
جون ومتى  يسأل أي شخص
كيف حالك بطريقة أو بأخرى كيف تسير الأمور في
نهايتك ،
لم أجب عنها مطلقًا بعد الآن ولكن إجابتي هي أنها
تتراوح من مقياس من أنا مشغول أو أنا
مشغول أو ليس لدي دقيقة
خدش معك ولكن عندما سارت الأمور
على عاتقي ، أجبت بأنني في وضع الزومبي
مشغول ، لذا فقد واجهت bocinas yeni
يقلل بشكل حاسم من
جودة حياتي ، كان نوعًا من الهوس ، لقد
كان إدمانًا وهو كذلك
تحديا للتخزين  ع تمامًا كما أنت
مدمن على السجائر أو التسوق
لبعض النساء ، لذا فإن رحلتي لا تنتهي
هنا صيف 2015 لأن الجميع مشغول
بالذهاب لقول مرحبًا أو نشر
صور على Instagram of the sea of the sand
hashtag no filter or hashtag fun  في
الشمس ، كنت مشغولاً بأخذ غابة محاسبية وسيطة
وليس ذلك فحسب ، بل
تم فتح باب التقديم لاتحاد الطلاب
وأردت التقديم كرئيس
ولأولئك الذين لا يعرفون أن الكرسي أمر
كبير وأعتقد  يسير الأشخاص من الجامعة
لدرجة أنهم كانوا دليلًا حيًا
على ذلك ، لذا فقد تعلمت الكثير في
العامين ونصف العام الماضيين واعتقدت
أن الأمر سيضيع إذا ضيعت
هذه الفرصة ، ففعلت وتقدمت بطلب
بعد ذلك  الجولة الثانية من المقابلات ،
يأتي مصطفى في الرئيس
الحالي ، وقال لي الرئيس الحالي لاتحاد الطلاب
أنني سأرد
ونضع النتيجة النهائية ، حيث كان الخوف في الأسبوع
الماضي هو العاطفة المسيطرة الوحيدة التي
شعرت أنني صليت بها في صمت يورو
اليورو / إنرجايزر  تم
تعييني كشخص مستقل بذاته ، وكان هذا
غريبًا حقًا لأنني أضع نفسي في حالة من
العذاب لماذا تقدمت بطلب من
البداية وأهدرت الكثير من الوقت في
كتابة خطة مكونة من 30 صفحة ، ثم
أدركت أنني لا أريد ذلك
لقد مر يوم الخميس وبسرعة
كما كان يوم الجمعة ، ثم كان
صباح يوم السبت ، كانت الصورة الوحيدة التي
يمكنني رؤيتها بوضوح
أمامي هي كرسي العام الماضي وأنا أعلم أنني
لا أريد أن أكون  إنه بالكاد وضع
حياته معًا وكانت هذه هي اللحظة
التي أدركت فيها أنه الفصل الدراسي الأخير لي ، وهذا
ليس ما أريد القيام به ، وليس كيف
أريد أن أقضيها ، لذا كان من
المفترض أن يتصل معظمهم في الساعة العاشرة ولن يفعل
ذلك  اتصلت به في الساعة 12 صباحًا وأخبرته
مصطفى أنني أصبحت خجولًا
وبعد ذلك كانت هناك فترة توقف طويلة جدًا
في هاتف المنزل من Sarfaraz
وكبرى البائعين Yanni helena de tinta haga
haga كيف صلبة 40 luda قرن
وإحساس شبكي نهائي و  الرهينة الأخيرة
في e هو الغناء في Phantom
تدوين يعني g  وأقر الهاغين هل نحن
بخير إيسي د.  دينيس على محار آدم
سكيس جاء ، لذا في هذه اللحظة
بالذات قررت أنني أريد أن أعمل في
عملي ، والباقي في سلام ، كنت أرتدي أعمالي مثل
شارة الشرف فقط لم يكن هناك شرف
لي ، ثم فكرت في نفسي
لماذا فعلت  افعل هذا بنفسي أو كيف
انتهى بي المطاف بالعيش مثل هذا ما
نسيت أنني كنت إنسانًا
فكرت في أنك تفعله عندما
ننسى أن هناك المزيد والمزيد من الوقت
للقيام بالأشياء وهناك أفضل وقت
لقضاء وقت الفراغ  أقل من انعكاس
ما لم يحن الوقت فقط عندما
نسينا أنه يمكننا إجراء محادثات
مع الأشخاص الذين يهموننا
أكثر من دون أي صمت ولا توقف في حالة
عدم الاندفاع ولكن هذا المرض
معدي نعم المرضى بعد
أن يعاني المرضى من هذه الحالة  لذلك
أريد أن أرفع الأيدي أنا متأكد ولكن
يمكنكم جميعًا أن تتذكروا هؤلاء الأشخاص الخمسة
الذين وقعوا ضحية لهذا المرض وأنت
تعرف سبب ذلك لأننا
شروط مسبقة للاعتقاد بأن هذا
هو نمط السلوك الذي يتعين علينا
اتباعه  لذلك خصص آباؤنا مالطا
لأنهم يعملون 12 ساعة في اليوم خمسة أيام في
الأسبوع يقومون بالأعمال الروتينية في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ،
لذلك تم تعلم لانس بين العمل والمنزل
أننا دائمًا في الخارج على
أجهزتنا طوال الوقت المزعج لذلك دون
الشعور بذلك  بدأنا بنمذجة هذه
السلوكيات للأطفال
وإخوتنا الذين واجهناهم ، لذلك
بدأوا يعتقدون أن هذا هو
نمط السلوك الذي يجب عليهم
اتباعه ، فنحن دائمًا ننتقل إلى
وتيرة وطاقة من حولنا ، لكن ذلك
لن يحدث.  كن على هذا النحو ، في هذه اللحظة
شعرت أن هذا هو السعر الذي دفعته
لكوني مشغولًا ، ما هو السعر الذي
أعتقد أنه عندما استسلمت لعملي ،
أعلم أنني كنت
أفتقد قدرًا غير عادي من الوقت
لكوني رئيسًا لكوني قلبًا
كاملًا لأكون حاضرًا مع الأشخاص الذين
أحبهم أكثر من غيرهم ، فما هي الأسعار
التي دفعتها ، كانت الحميمية ، لقد كان هذا
التقارب هو ما نتوق إليه جميعًا ونريد جميعًا
أن نكون محبوبين ونريد جميعًا أن نقدمه  كل منهم
نريد أن نتلقى  لكنك
حقًا تحب شخصًا ما ليحب شخصًا ما حقًا ،
يجب ألا تكون هناك عين واحدة
على أجهزة الكمبيوتر المحمولة الخاصة بنا في واحدة عالية على
والدينا ولا عين واحدة على إخوتنا في
عين واحدة على جهاز iPhone الخاص بنا ، فنحن بحاجة إلى
التواجد هناك بكل إخلاص والعمل
التجاري  كتبت لي عن هذا
الاتجاه وأنا متأكد من أنه يفرك كل
واحد منكم من هذا بدوره ،
لذلك فكرت في نفسي لماذا
تحب المرأة البالغة عندما تسبب
ضغوطًا في حياتها طواعية مثل من يفعل ذلك
وجدت الإجابة وهي  لم يكن
رائعًا ، كان ذلك لأنني كنت خائفًا من مساعدة
نفسي ، فنحن جميعًا نخاف من أنفسنا
لأننا نعيش في مجتمع
يحتفل بالنشاط ، فنحن جميعًا
مُعرَّفون بما نقوم به من خلال وظائفنا من خلال ما يفعله
الناس بما ننتجه ، لذا فهو
الجزء الأول من  المعلومات التي
نشاركها في اجتماع ، تعرف ما
الذي تم القيام به في المواعدة ، فماذا نفعل نحن
نتخلى عن بطاقة العمل ، لذلك نقوم بتقليل
أنفسنا بحيث تكون قطعة ورق بأربعة سنتيمترات في
خمسة سنتيمترات
بدأنا نعتقد أن  نحن أكثر من ذلك ،
سنكون أكثر قيمة من
الآخرين وآخر ما نقوم به نحن على
الأقل أقل قيمة من الأشخاص
المحكوم عليهم بالفشل أو نفعل المزيد أنا لست هنا
لأعطيك أي حل منطقي لهذا
ولكن أعتقد أنني  لقد توصلنا إلى إدراك
أننا في الحقيقة لا نعيش حياة إنسانية حقيقية ،
فنحن جميعًا نعرف ما نريده
جميعًا نريد حياة متوازنة ، ونريد جميعًا
وجودًا ذا معنى ولكننا لا نتبع الخطوات
التالية ، وبالتالي الخطوات التي
تعلمون أنني قرأتها في مقال  أنه في جميع
الثقافات الإسلامية أو في
الثقافات العربية عندما تسأل شخصًا ما باللغة العربية
كيف انضممت إليه ، فهذا نوع من الاختباء ،
فنحن حريصون على أحبك ، لذا
فأنت تسأل حقًا عن الرأس
فما هذه اليد التي  نحن نستفسر
عنها في حالة قلبنا ، لذلك عندما
أسألك عن حالك ، أسألك
عن حالة قلبك في هذه
اللحظة حقًا ، لا أسأل عن عدد
العناصر الموجودة في قائمة مهامك أو كيف  العديد من
رسائل البريد الإلكتروني الموجودة في صندوق الوارد الخاص بك
أريد حقًا أن أعرف كيف هو قلبك
د  لذا في المرة القادمة ، توقف مؤقتًا
افحص نفسك ، افحص قلبك ،
افحص روحك ثم شاركه ،
أخبرني شيئًا عن قلبك
وأخبرني شيئًا عن روحك ، لذا في خريف
2015 تركت عملي أرقد بسلام ،
قررت أنني لا أريد أن أعرّف
بنفسي من خلال عملي وعرّف نفسي من خلال
كوني ، توقفت عن تعريف نفسي
بالوقت على مدار الساعة وبدأت في
قياس التجارب وقياس الوقت مع
كل التجارب الثمينة التي شاركتها
مع من حولي ، أخذت وعدًا بأنني
أخذت وعدًا بأنني  سوف
يتباطأ بالنسبة لي ، يتطلب الأمر
قدرًا لا يصدق من الجهد ولكني
أحاول القيام بالأشياء بشكل مختلف
وآمل حقًا أن يقول والداي أخي
أصدقائي أنني أحاول حقًا
أن أكون حاضرًا للاستماع إلى  أنت
ولكي تفكر في
وجودك ووجودي حتى الآن معي اخترت اليوم
يا
أنت